terrible day for the TSA the department
responsible for airport security today
the Acting Director was forced to step
down when it was revealed that the TSA
failed to detect 95% of the weapons and
explosives that undercover federal
agents sent through airport security as
a test
95% now as you may expect this was
terribly embarrassing for the TSA they
are eager to tell their side of the
story we have a senior TSA agent here
tonight please welcome Frank Bautista
Frank let's come on out here
[Applause]
thanks Robbie they're applauding you as
if you're real that's great Frank
everyone wants to know how did the TSA
miss 95% of the weapons that were sent
through your terminals by undercover
agents how okay first of all Conan
they're focusing only on the negatives
and not mentioning all the items the TSA
successfully intercepted things like
this 4 ounce bottle of shampoo 4 ounces
a full ounce over the allowable limit
liquid death we stopped it ok we also
stopped this pacemaker right here yeah
when this prosthetic leg
what yeah can easily be weapon though no
no no that's not you're just pointing
that that isn't it imagine it now
cornucopia dumb stupid none of those
things are dangerous
what about all the weapons and
explosives you guys did let through what
about that that's the story well there
again people aren't getting the whole
story
for instance this here looks like a
perfectly normal tube of tennis balls
but would you believe that two of these
are actually grenades yeah you can see
that very good yeah
and this here obvious it's a seat this
looks just like a normal Dumbo does not
look like a barbell that's not does not
look anything like a barbell or this
keychain that's it's fine
that's a samurai sword samurai sword ooh
am I supposed to do take their keys away
how're they gonna get into their house
yeah and you kid you can't blame us for
letting this cute little dog through
proper guys who's gonna say no that cute
little face but oh what's that Toby
stole more needs to go for a walk okay
my guess is you're gonna go backstage
where your dog it's made of dynamite
makes a blow up sound and that's how the
sketch ends pretty much you know what
that's exactly what's gonna yeah I'm
thinking
[Applause]
and he was that an explosion or did an
old woman exhale etcetera I said crap is
after the explosion a bomb rolled out
wouldn't the wind the bomb blow up
apparently not nope nope look bad at
rehearsal look bad here hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography